welcome to this video yeah this is
another episode of chess Giants the
series that shows great games
instructive games beautiful games from
the past and it is also meant to
introduce players to you in a way very
often then players of everyone know and
so it's not like oh never seen a game
off in this case what winnings before so
good to see one but still it's good to
look at those all-time classic games and
see what we can learn from them even now
nowadays I mean yeah this game is from
1936 so quite old and still twelve years
before bid winning actually became world
champion he already was a top player at
the time this was from the Nottingham
tournament his opponent is Milan vidmar
back then a top player it's difficult
for those old times to really appreciate
how how strong a player was because they
didn't really have like we have today
rating system but with my certainty was
among the top 10 20 players in the world
he was from Shia now it gets tricky
politically it was born in Ljubljana
nowadays Slovenia but during his life
this this part of Europe has undergone
many changes from being Slovenia to
Yugoslavia to austria-hungarian empire
and so on so he was served a really good
player let's see what happens in this
game but Winnick opens with c4 he
regularly played d4 c4 Knight f3 the
close games very rarely did he open e
for it happened but not very often
e6 night a 3d file d4 Knight f6 so we
get a Queen's Gambit a classical Queens
gambit yeah now Whitmer plays Nightbeat
seven and we need to remember this is
1936 and this is only a couple of years
after them World Championship match
between Ella Cohen and kappa blanka
where they had this position on the
board in almost all of the games back
then they believe that not bd7 is the
way to play in the Queens gambit
declined it's still a playable move of
course nowadays the main focus is on
page six bishop h form and then either
the Lasker variation yeah as you can see
recognize the Lasker variation it was
even in existence back then very solid
up to this day autumn after Bishop h4
like can also play b6 the Tata Cova
variation or tanzaku Vaughn mckagan up
on the refs key GMB variation as a
result encode and they're among the
Russian players I believe yeah
Tata Cova also a player of the time so
these variations were starting to
develop at the time but still the
absolute main move 9b d7 and played here
it is a bit less flexible than the other
continuations yeah but we Nick now
played Bishop d3 which is a bit uncommon
nowadays however what we Nick didn't
mind to play this move as it usually
leads to isolated Queen porn positions
and but winning always liked to play the
high QP positions especially from the
white side where very often compared to
some black nqp positions you have more
active development yeah why does it need
to iqp positions often we would see in
the game I just want to show one thing
that the main movie is actually rooks
Seaborn even was at the time it was the
main move and after that black very
often played c6 introducing the kappa
blanka variation at the time developed
kappa blanka an interesting thing is
that nowadays after Luke c1 and black
players sometimes opt for the capture
and after Bishop c4 they go a6 intending
to push b5 later Bishop d7 and c5 to get
a healthy development in the style of
the marin variation however white
normally goes a for him to prevent that
and after c5 castles we get to this
position this is a modern theoretical
position not something that you see that
often but it is played by grandmasters
it's important to keep this position in
mind to compare it to the game here
white basically has an extra tempo with
rook c1 that he has kept captured in one
move on C form if we look at the game
continuation ya put Vinick playing
Bishop d3 now what black could have done
he didn't play that but what he could
have done this he could have taken and
play a six this is probably the way a
modern Grandmaster would approach the
position the ideas that you basically
are tempo up on the variation that I
showed from before again black wants to
go b5 and c5 and if he manages to do
that he will have solved his main
problem that Bishop c8 would get a good
job on b7 so a4 is played and now I have
to see five castles we have exactly the
same position as before but white is
lacking the rooks e1 move which probably
is a useful move it said it's in half
open file possibly an open file after C
takes it takes diva deform so this is
probably what black should do a possible
continuation is something like that
again black we put the bishop on one c6
it's very important to note
that with a four White has weakened his
queenside this is helpful for various
counter place for example if we imagine
a position I just put it on the board
like groupie 157 just imagine a position
like that here like might have moves
like that all of a sudden using this
unprotected Bishop attacking b2 or
putting a piece on before which is also
we can square so this insertion of a six
in a form has helped like quite
considerably in the game with my album
we go back he did not take he played c5
immediately after castles he now went
for the iqp position so this all is
similar but the differences with the
other move water there was a six a four
inserted if black now plays a six we are
not obliged to play a form not at all we
can simply retreat after b5 and just
yeah play on play for d5 for example we
can do this voluntary retreat and if now
b5 is coming there is there's d5 being a
typical motif breaking in the center
why does not force to play a form I
think that bit mass move order is really
not very precise but this is pretty much
modern-day modern-day thinking back then
they were just going to the iqp and
started to blockade it those little
differences is subtle points they were
not really well known back then however
what we see in this game this is from
1936 it's really pioneering work on the
iqp plain bible Vinick um of course
those positions were known but people
were still a bit in doubt if the IQ P
could be a good thing to have it was
still sort of from yeah the fact that
that Steinitz head
on chess he of course introduced the
first basic positional ideas but he was
very much hmm in favor of combating the
iqp and not playing with it he won
instructive games for instance in his
match against suka taught in the 1880s
so people were still a little bit in
doubt I mean tarish was a big fan of
that I could be of course but people
didn't really at the time they couldn't
really figure out this is a good thing
what is this and what Winnick was pretty
much taking the side of the iqp and
showing the kind of attacking
possibilities brings so black played
Bishop d7 Queen D 3 and Knight bd5
classical blockading strategy on the fur
on the d5 square 95 Bishop c6 this type
of set up what was known back then from
the from the games of Steinitz and it
was believed to be okay for black blacks
position in fact is probably okay but it
is not the best that he could could go
from if we just compare this position
and insert the moves a 4 and a 6 which
was possible to get for black this is
just much better and it's like Queen b6
gains and strengths so what is the
continuation here for white but we Nick
now plays a simple but strong move he
plays rook 81 yeah
this er might look a bit mysterious why
would you put the rook behind the pawn
yeah this has this has two reasons one
reason is and this is a pretty simple
one it lends protection to the opponent
especially considering that white wants
to move the Queen away where - we will
we would seem quite shortly the other
reason why rook on the default behind
the pawn might be useful
it's the d4 d5 break very often this
break can play a useful role at the
moment of course d5 is very very
securely protected but if the knight
moves away from d5
d4 d5 the d4 divide push can become an
idea yeah black now went night before
and I think this is questionable
probably playable but questionable I
guess rook c8 should be preferred and
just getting this piece into play
possibly using it on the sefa what I
don't like about night before in
comparison is that it yeah it gets a
gets a piece away from the center and
loses some time in a way to provoke
something that white wanted to do anyway
Queen edge 3 yeah why to h3 h3 is an
excellent square for the Queen in this
structure because of two reasons or even
three reasons if you want one is it puts
pressure on e6 this combined pressure is
very useful this is also reaching all
the way to f7 of course
so Knight f7 is a typical way to
procedure something that black
definitely must must attend to another
reason why the Queen is good on aged 3
years it looks at age 7 so if y it gets
a bishop to c2 at the moment this is
protected by the knight but if he gets a
bishop here there is this may threat
coming on h7 combined with this pressure
on the night this is very dangerous and
the third thing if black decides to push
away the bishop with h6 we might have to
sacrifice so the Queen is very well
placed on h3 supporting the upcoming
attack black now played Bishop d5 what
we can look at is what about age 6 if
black tries to yeah kick this Bishop
away in fact and this is I think bit
remarkable here already the sacrifice on
h6 is working and winning it's not even
interesting or in attack or something it
is winning white is winning here because
of the threat a3 pushing the night away
now and then look t3
another point behind rook t1 the rukon D
one is always able to get in this rook
lift with a knight on d5 you cannot
really lift by a is for your c3 but
where a d3 you can only now it is
protected on none on d3 the square by
the knight but White's plan is simply as
a3 Rock d3 and black has absolutely no
defense against that for example if we
let's say look at this Knight ft4 it's
it's really not mattering they they all
win here white can take bishop takes and
a3 yeah and now this Knight is attacked
and once it moves or gets taken Luke d3
g3 is totally totally devastating there
is no no defense IAM absolutely none
let's say a five III yeah it's the same
business you take I mean at the end does
route d3 g3 and black black gets totally
guilty on the king so a very very
dangerous attacker h6 is not possible so
what about g6 can you play g6 to sort of
bolster your defenses you cannot just
push up h6 rupee eight and should be six
and white wins yeah this is the strength
of those combined pieces yeah here we
see that why this white is just winning
winning in the house so a very dangerous
attack is brewing black must be very
very careful here in his defense yeah
what is the best defense hmm not quite
sure what he was playing is probably not
that bad
I actually prefer to play Knight B to B
to d5 which looks kinda sick because you
just have gone to before but maybe it's
still the best defense to try to get
more pieces to the to the defense of
course he didn't do that it's really not
the kind of move you play you move
United before and then back but okay
he went Bishop d5 yeah try to to reduce
this pressure okay
but winning took on d5 gaining the
bishop in the process the next move now
definitely is a mistake I think what
black needed to do is to take on d5 now
with the F Knight the the thing that
black should try to achieve is to trade
trade pieces to reduce the attacking
potential and here here white hazard has
a choice he has two interesting moves he
can take on his seven just for the sake
of tempo so that after Queen takes we
immediately can go f4 intending f5 this
F pawn battering ram that opens up this
diagonal will be seen in the game but in
comparison it is less effective and the
wood you see in the game why it is even
stronger stronger there the here white
definitely enjoys an advantage but this
is still a defensible position it's
uncomfortable but defensible the big
problem is that white simply has all
pieces in active active attacking
positions and black is just a bit
passive however white also can consider
this move which is not as let's say yeah
it's not as quick and fluent like Bishop
e7 f4 but it keeps the two bishops and
still intense f4 f5 this has the added
advantage then it keeps those
sacrificial possibilities like Bishop h6
in there an interesting interesting
choice both seems seems okay but I think
black needed to do that he had to go
night-night F 35 he went to capture with
the B night so here that B takes d5 was
played and now the next move is pretty
much something that you probably expect
when you have
seen the idea earlier f/4 yeah and this
is just very very strong
why does using all this forces the look
on f1 all of a sudden is developed
basically by playing f4
this is sometimes that something that
people often forget with pawn pushes you
can sometimes develop your rooks on
squares where they actually already are
sitting you know like you can sometimes
just push h4 to play rook h3 using the
rook on the national square or here you
can use the F pawn to get this better in
bettering realm of the board with f5
opening up the position also for the
rook All Whites pieces are participating
in that tech and the big problem is that
after f5 black has a hard time to not
take on f5 and after that this whole
construction with the pressure on f7 on
e6 and on those pieces on d5 and f6 this
whole construction will fall apart black
here really has no defense if he goes g6
for example he didn't play that but if
he goes g6 to try to block this this is
nothing that really is to very some
white can just play Bishop h6 Ruby 8 and
again f5 what a smashing attack if black
now takes on f5 we just play here oops
here and black will mate will be mated
or lose the house so not possible and if
he takes with the e pawn this is not
very very soon as well we just take it
yeah it's it's the same thing black
captures squeegee 3s totally totally
deadly it's no no defense whatsoever and
yet the pressure is just piling up for
example if black plays Queen c8 hoping
that rook move rook retreat will lead to
some relief as yeah does this hope is
easily easily shattered with Bishop d5
after that there is no way out
yes black now takes on f5 there is even
this funny move g4 attacking the Queen
and something like something like that
Islam is a total is a total win for
white
yeah the attack is just too strong
especially if you consider that all
pieces are participating in building up
this huge depression so g6 was not
played he played not this but rook c8
yet after rook c8 I think it's clear
what was doing f5 this was the idea or
no and now after a five black is
basically not able to keep this pawn on
e6 to to sort of yeah support this whole
construction of those those two knights
black now has to take few plays Queen d6
not taking white is more than one good
continuation one good move however is
rupee one yeah intensifying this
depression yeah black he really has
something like this for example if we
consider this now White has a ton of
threats it's really amazing here here I
mean far too much far too much
26 for example rook air-five we get we
get in Brooke Brooke e to f5 Evan even
and it's nothing nothing black I can do
here we just put some more moves on the
board for example
yeah I can resign with a clear
conscience there are there are many
possible possible lines but they all
lead to disaster so what Whitman did is
after f5 he just he just took it and
white recaptured with their porn every
day F rook sorry the rook yeah Queen d6
young it's it's not defending but there
was nothing really to defend the
position anymore
rook c7 I could think of maybe trying to
do something here but the pressure is
far too far too far time something like
this for example even Bishop h6 is a
possibility attacking the King directly
this is just one possible line and note
that here everything hangs f7 hangs and
like like it's defenseless yeah it is
too much pressure if pieces are taking
it's usually too much yeah well would
mark played Queen d6 and now there is a
pretty simple tactical sequence to to
win the game but Winnick now took on f7
rook takes yeah if the King takes looks
it looks quite precarious right yeah
this is actually more than one way to
win but this is this is a simplest
removing the defender of the d5 Knight
and after something like that we will
have a disastrous discover check just
one way to win this there's many yeah he
went with the not with the king but he
went with the rook capture and now white
oh god f6 Bishop takes rook takes and
now we see an additional problem whoops
this is saying as well like went to
cover that
yeah ATM but Winnick is doing the final
improvement look attacking the Queen
with the tempo
Oh Queen takes is a very easy win
so instead create was played and now
Rupert is seven-letter resignation so he
have it ma resigned the game yeah this
is one of the all-time
iqp classics yeah showing one way to
attack with the isolated Queen point I
mean more than one way but it shows one
particular attacking device very clearly
the F pawn the F pawn advance using this
pawn in order to get your rook into the
game and removing this with F four and
five this defense of the d5 blockading
Square where you ultimately lift the
blockade and break through on this
diagonal yeah this also shows that the
attacking potential of the isolated
Queen pond is very much yeah it's very
strong if specially if black has chosen
a relatively passive setup like it
happened in this game nowadays very
often people tend to try to attack the
iqp more than to blockade it here we see
a situation on the board where the pawn
on d4 is blockaded by the night that's
all nice but well the deep pawn is
supposed to be weakness but black is
never going to take it when there's a
knight on d5 and white basically plays
around all that and builds up this use
pressure huge pressure on the on the
Kings side to ultimately launch a
winning mating attack so it's it's
really something that people should
appreciate that they shouldn't be afraid
of the isolated queen pawn and they
should try to add some lines to the
opening repertoire to get this get these
kind of positions on the board it's
really something that you you need to be
able to play as a good chess player
because a pop-up Tiger diamond again and
iqp positions very often are they're a
promising because
have such good peace play yeah I hope
you enjoyed this video showing one of
the classic what we need games it also
shows by the way one of good winning
some absolute strength if he got to a
position type that he knew and he had
studied before which is definitely the
case for this Queens gambit occupy
positions in positions that he knew when
he had some sort of knowledge advantage
on the opponent they was absolutely
deadly I mean he really played those
kind of games then where every move sort
of looks like the best one probably he
managed to play on every move the best
movie and it was all a natural flow
there was no temple given law or time
lost or whatever it was just like the
perfect perfect punishment of blacks
somewhat passive and imprecise opening
play yeah I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching